MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR
REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HEARING.
WE WILL BEGIN TO CALL ROLE
[inaudible]
LOW HERE.
ARAMBULA.
CHEN.
CHILL.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN FONG GIPSON HERE GLORIA
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN IRWIN.
MEDINA.
MULLIN OBERNOLTE TING.
OKAY WE HAVE A SERVICE A CORE
AND AGAIN FOR HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS
THE FALLING BILLS HAVE.
BEEN PULLED WHICH IS SB SIX D.
SEVEN MCGUIRE SB FIVE SIX NINE
STONE IN SB SIX OH ONE MORAL.
ABOUT AND THOSE WOULD BE HAVE
BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHORS -- SO
BEGINNING IN FILE ITEM ORDER
WILL BEGIN THEN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE.
CENTER WELCOME AT THIS DOES
ENJOY IN IRAQ -- SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES AL
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO VISIT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
WELL HOT -- GOOD MORNING.
I WILL -- FROM THEN I WOULD BE
VERY QUICK -- LONG STORY SHORT
AS HE WANTED THE EIGHTY FIVE
EXPLAINS PROHIBITIONS ALREADY
STATURE IMPROPERLY USING COUNTY
NEEDS FOR CANADA'S PRODUCTS
INCLUDE ANY SIMILAR SOUNDING
NAME OF APPELLATIONS IS LIKELY
TO MISS REPRESENT.
THE ORIGIN OF THE PRODUCT AND IT
SURE IS OUR PRODUCTS ARE LABELED
IN WAYS THAT LEAD CONSUMERS TO
BELIEVE THERE FROM CERTAIN AREAS
WHICH THEY WOULD NOT BE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH MEMBERS -- IN MISTER CHAIR
FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TEAR COVERAGE ACTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE HUBBLE
CATEGORIES LANCE HUMBOLDT COUNTY
GROWERS LINES AS THE VOICE OF
THE HUMBLE COUNTY CANNABIS
INDUSTRY.
REPRESENTING NEARLY TWO HUNDRED
PLUS LEGAL RESPONSIBLE PLANT
TOUCHING BUSINESSES -- REACHED
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND THINK THAT A SENATOR FOR HIS
WORK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI LINDSAY ROBINSON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
RAPPERS AND ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE --
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL AND WE THINK THE AUTHOR AS
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO MY
PHONE NAME AFFILIATION IF YOU
WISH TO DO SO.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAUL
YOU ARE WE HAVE THE BOARDS TO
RISE AND HUMBLE MENDOCINO
COUNTIES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
CARE MARKETS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
AND JENNIFER COMPUTER THOUGH ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE IT ANY
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM CNUMBERS SEE
NONE SENATOR MCCARTY WAS TO
CLOSE [inaudible]
BY YOUR ABSOLUTELY THE THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION A SECOND COUNTY
SIXTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB ONE EIGHTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU
PASSED COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
LOW I KNOW I PRO.
PRO AYE ARAMBULA.
AYE BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN FONG FONG
AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA BUT IN AYE
MULLIN?
OBERNOLTE TING.
TING AYE.
AT THAT BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CONTENTS FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
JONES.
SENATE JONES GOOD MORNING YET
AGAIN YOUR BILL HAVE BEFORE US
HAS AND I SUPPORT A CONDITION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
PLEASE FEEL FREE PRESENT
WHENEVER I LOVE THIS COMMITTEE.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE COMEDIAN
ENTIRE BUILDING INCLUDING ALL
THE ONES I SIT ON SMARMY MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS A GREAT
BILL -- ALLOWING TIME SURE
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE A STRIKE A
SLIGHT CHANGE.
IN -- HOW THEY DO BUSINESS AND
OFFER COMMENDATIONS FOR THEIR
POTENTIAL CUSTOMERS JOHN
CALDWELL IS HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE ANY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOUVERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT?
SEE NINE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEN ON THERE'S A
MOTION A SECOND TWENTY SIX THREE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT MOTIONS TO
PASS TO COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
LOW I THOUGHT I PRO.
I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BLOOM CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU CUNNINGHAM.
AT CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN FONG
FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN OBERNOLTE TING?
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
MEMBERS APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU CAN RENTS.
THE MOVING ON TO FILE AND A
NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS SB SIX
FIFTY BY SENATOR RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING CENTER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR CHEN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT SB
SIX FIFTY I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS SB SIX
FIFTY WILL CREATE ACCOUNTS FOR
MEDICATION ADVISORY TASK FORCE.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF IDENTIFYING
HOW TO BEST ASSIST CANCER
PATIENTS WERE IN DIRE NEED OF
MEDICATION.
THE TASK FOR THE TASK FORCE WILL
ANALYZE THE CURRENT OF DRUG
REPOSITORY SYSTEM ANOTHER
BARRIER SUCCESS SEEN AFFORDABLE
MEDICATION.
IN A TIMELY MANNER THE TASK
FIRST ALL RIGHT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND BOARD OF
PHARMACY.
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE BEST
METHODS FOR ENSURING AND I NEWS
I NEEDED MEDICATIONS CAN BE
TRANSFERRED TO PATIENTS WHO NEED
IT.
CALIFORNIA MUST DO ALL IT CAN TO
SERVE THIS WOMAN WILL POPULATION
AND SB.
SIX FIFTY WILL PROVIDE A ROADMAP
FOR FUTURE LEGISLATION.
WITH ME WE HAVE -- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TWO WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO OFFER THEIR
TESTIMONY.
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE THE NET
SHORT IN AUTUMN OCTANT SPONSORS
OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP TO TWO
MINUTES IF YOU WISH TO DO SO THE
SUCH SHORT WITH THE ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ONCOLOGY
WERE.
PROUD TO BE SPONSORS OF THE BILL --
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL IS
REALLY NECESSARY TO REALLY LOOK
AT OUR CURRENT CANCER DRUG --
ARE DRUG RECYCLING PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA WELL AS WORKING IN
SOME PLACES AND FOR SOME
PATIENTS IT IS NOT WORKING FOR
CANCER PATIENTS.
ARE PHYSICIANS HE PATIENTS EVERY
DAY THAT HAVE ON USE I NEEDED
CANCER MEDICATIONS MAY ALSO SEE
EVERY DAY THAT PATIENTS THAT ARE
IN DESPERATE NEED OF THEIR
MEDICATIONS AND CANNOT AFFORD IT
OR CANNOT WAIT -- FOR THE
MEDICATIONS TO ARRIVE -- WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS -- REPORT WILL
ALLOW US TO LOOK VERY CLOSELY AT
HOW WE CAN ENSURE THAT ANCER
PATIENTS AND THEIR PHYSICIANS
CAN PARTNER TO MAKE SURE THAT
CANCER PATIENTS GET THOSE
MEDICATIONS AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
AND THAT WE DON'T WASTE -- IT
VERY EXPENSIVE VERY IMPORTANT --
UNUSED UNNEEDED MEDICATIONS SO
WE ARE DRIVE VOTE.
HI MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AUTOMOTIVE SMITH WITH THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK ALSO PROD CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL -- CANCER
IS ONE OF THE LEADING CAUSES OF
DEATH AND DISEASE IN THE U. S..
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
ESTIMATES THAT ROUGHLY ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION NEW CASES.
OF CANCER WILL BE DIAGNOSED IN
THE U. S..
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND MORE
THAN FIFTEEN MILLION AMERICANS
OF OUR LIVING TODAY -- WITH THE
KIDS ARE HISTORY.
NOT ONLY DOES CANCER TAKE
ENORMOUS TOLL ON THE HEALTH OF
PATIENTS AS SURVIVORS AND ALSO
HAS A TREMENDOUS FINANCIAL
IMPACT -- WE ARE HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX FIFTY BECAUSE
THE TASK FORCE WILL LOOK AT THE
POTENTIAL POTENTIAL WAYS TO
REDUCE THESE COSTS AND SAVE MORE
CANCER.
PATIENTS LIFE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
SING NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
RUSSIAN SPEAKING OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO QUESTION COMES FROM COULD YOU
EVER SEND A REVIEW DO WISH TO
CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
AS WE KNOW.
SOME OF US ARE MOST OF US HAVE
BEEN TOUCHED IN ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER BY COUNTS RUN THIS IS
ABOUT AXIS AXIS TO PEOPLE THAT
DON'T HAVE THE MEANS.
TO ACQUIRE THE PROPER MEDICATION --
JUST AS A SIDE NOTE WE HAVE
FOURTEEN STATES THAT ALREADY
HALF COUNTS FOR SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS AND I THINK CALIFORNIA
NEEDS.
TO BE A LEADER IN THIS IN THIS
RESPECT WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR
RIFLE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB SIX FIFTY MOTIONS YOU PASS
ADMITTED TO COMMITTEE ON HEALTH
LOW THE I. BRO BRO I ARAMBULA I
MEAN DON'T AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE FONG FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GLORIA GLORIA I
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND RIVER
FINALLY FILE AND A NUMBER SEVEN
WHICH IS SB.
SIX FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR MONEY.
THE MONEY WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING.
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY SEVEN
AUTHORIZES THE COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER. TO
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE ON THE CONDITION
ACREAGE PRODUCTION IN VALUE OF
CANNABIS.
THIS INFORMATION WOULD BE IN
ADDITION. TO THEIR SUBMITTED
ANNUAL CROP REPORT SOME COUNTIES
ARE FINDING THAT BECAUSE
CANNABIS IS CURRENTLY NOT
INCLUDED IN THE ANNUAL CROP
REPORT IT IS NOT AN ACCURATE
REPRESENTATION.
OF THE COUNTY'S AGRICULTURAL
CULTIVATION.
NORMALIZING CANNABIS IS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT WILL
ENCOURAGE UNLICENSED GROWERS TO
COME FORWARD AND BECOME
LEGITIMATE.
PERMITTED IN TAX PAYING
BUSINESSES.
THIS IS A VOLUNTARY OPT IN IT
WOULD BE IF THEY COUNTY AG
COMMISSIONER IN THE COUNTY
CHOOSES TO SUPPLY THIS
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION.
WITH THAT AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME AND
I DO HAVE -- JENNIFER HELLO
REPRESENTING THE COUNTY OF
MONTEREY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS WILL BE HI
JENNIFER COMPETE ON BEHALF OF
THAT COUNTY OF MONTEREY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS -- WE ARE SPONSORING
THIS BILL -- BACK IN THE
EIGHTIES THE COUNTY MONTEREY WAS
FLOURISHING WITH GREENHOUSES AND
CUT FLOWERS -- AND THEN THE
LATIN AMERICAN MARKET GOT INTO
CUT FLOWERS AND COMPLETELY
DECIMATED AND MONTEREY COUNTY WE
HAVE TONS OF GREENHOUSES SITTING
EMPTY -- HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE OF THE LOSS OF ALL THOSE
JOBS AND WE'VE SEEN A RENEWED
INTEREST IN MONTEREY COUNTY AND
USING THOSE GREENHOUSES FOR
CANNABIS -- WE FEEL LIKE THE
COUNTY SHOULD SUPPORT THESE
GROWERS AS THEY MOVE INTO THIS
BUSINESS AND HAVING A DOCUMENT.
THAT REPORTS ON THOSE CANNABIS
NUMBERS WILL JUST HELP THE LEAD.
TO VALIDATE THE MARKET AND HELP
INVESTORS COME INTO MONTEREY
COUNTY -- TO SUPPORT CANNABIS
BUSINESS AS ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
CNN ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING SPEAKING OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME.
SEEING THAT QUESTIONS COMING
THROUGH COULD YOU MEMBERS DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
THANK YOU -- THANK YOU IT WILL
YOU DO WELL TO BE AT FOR HEMP AS
WELL OR JUST CANNABIS WE THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT.
HAM -- HOPEFULLY WILL BE ABLE TO
BE PART OF THE REGULAR CROP
REPORT THIS BILL IS TO HAVE AN
ADDENDUM TO THE CROP REPORT OR
AN ADDITIONAL REPORT IN ADDITION
TO THE CARPET PART.
BECAUSE HEMP IS GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS OF BEING LEGALIZED
ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL SO WE DON'T
INCLUDE HEMP IN THIS BILL.
BECAUSE THE HOPE IS IS THAT DOWN
THE ROAD IT'S GOING TO BE AND
THE REGULAR CARP REPORT AS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCT.
BUT IS NOT EXCLUDED CORRECT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM KEY MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR MONEY TO STAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SAID IN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN MOTIONS THE
PAST COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE
LOW HI WELL I BROKE.
ARAMBULA.
I BLOOM WE MIGHT CHEN CHEN AYE
CHIU TO AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. EGGMAN.
I MEAN I FONG.
I'M NOT VERY.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GLORIA.
THANK GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
DO NOT MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE REALTY I TING.
TING AYE.
THE BILL HAS FIFTEEN VOTES WILL
BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER MONEY.
MEMBERS WILL GO BACK IN FILE
ORDER. TO GO THROUGH THE BILL'S
AGAIN BUT JUST AS A HOUSEKEEPING
ITEM.
AGAIN.
THERE ARE THREE BILLS THAT HAVE
BEEN AUTHORED POLLS SB SIXTY
SEVEN BY CENTER REQUIRE SB FIVE
SIX NINE BY SENATOR STONE SB SIX
pHAVE BEEN AUTHOR PULLS -- SO
COMMITTEE KERRY WILL BE KILLED
IN ORDER WILL BEGIN WITH -- FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE SB ONE EIGHTY
FIVE MOTIONS YOU PASSED
COMMITTEE ON AGRICULTURE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE EGGMAN.
AGAIN THANK GLORIA.
I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I CHU.
CHU I SEVENTEEN VOTES THAT BILL
IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB FIVE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR JONES.
SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT MOTIONS
YOU PASSED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY BLOOM.
BUT MY CHAU CHIU AYE EGGMAN.
HI GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I SEVENTEEN
VOTES.
THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX SB SIX FIFTY BY SENATOR
RUBIO.
SB SIX FIFTY MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
CHAU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLD AYE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MULLIN. SEVENTY VOTES THE BILL
IS OUT AND THEN FINALLY FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB SIX FIFTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR MONEY.
SB SIX THIRTY SEVEN MOTIONS YOU
PASSED A COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE BRO.
FONG.
MCCARTY MULLIN. FIFTEEN VOTES
THAT BILLS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL FIVE MINUTES
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
ONE
EIGHTY FIVE MOTIONS YOU PASSED
ME ON I RECALLED HER VOTERS
EIGHTEEN ZERO THAT BILLS OUT.
SB FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT MOTIONS
YOU PASSED COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
VOTERS EIGHTEEN ZERO THE BILLS
OUT.
SB SIX FIFTY MOTIONS TO PASS
ADMITTED COMMITTEE ON HEALTH BUT
EIGHTEEN ZERO EIGHTEEN IS ARE
THE BILLS OUT.
SB SIX FIFTY SEVEN MOTIONS TO
PASS